about not to digress too much as well
but we bought mr. Johnson is saying
there when I you know how I just got
back from my Churchill fellowship I
discussed this week with all of you when
I was traveling to each of the different
countries every country has its own
version of stem and Sam is a massive
massive topic in America at the moment
so we can definitely make a lot of
international connections there that
would benefit the future now we need to
get through this a little bit quickly
this is our working document for our
project every group that is formed will
need to have one working document
between them the Edmodo has got this
document on there now for you to
download now because we are short of
time today I'm not going to get you to
download it but what we're going to do
is we're going to talk through the brief
with you which most of you are familiar
with anyway and then also the design
situation and from there as a class if
we have time we might start
brainstorming some research topics that
we need to investigate leave you with it
we already know that the acronym stem
stands for science technology
engineering mathematics that is why
we're all here we don't need to keep
going through that would you mind
traveling from of them the next thing
that you see in this document is the
outcomes now we have outcomes from each
of our different curriculum that we need
to address this door has math things he
needs to address I have technology
engineering things I need to address and
mr. arnon mrs. young have science
outcomes that they need to address all
of those outcomes are here for you to
read we're not going to read through
them because I don't have that much time
that we don't feel that it's necessary
the Holy
underneath that but what they pictures
all of us say you all know what we look
like if you your pictures miss sorry
your picture for sure we can have
pictures we have like 14 photos now as
you can see here we've got a little bit
of a description of how each teacher
will be involved in the program because
it's still probably a little bit unclear
to you so hopefully this helps to
clarify that a little bit you can read
through that at your own time everybody
knows what this is because we've been
using it for the last three weeks it is
our design process and it is the process
we're going to keep going through to
make our project we don't need to
recount that today well we do need to
recap today is our design proposal now
the red text boxes that you'll see
throughout the document adjust an
explanation of each of the steps
throughout the portfolio you can read
them in your own time what we want to
focus on today is we want to focus on
our design situation at our design group
so somebody else my last week for us ok
now just quickly before I I read this
this scenario is in addition to soil
throughs and travels through the top
playgrounds is this is the context that
we thought look this is a major issue
that is well it's quite unique to our
school there is there's no secondary
public school as large as us in the safe
that's why this is a problem scenario
that a lot of thinking and creativity
has to be poured into to understand so
as you know the school currently has a
population over 2,000 more than 130
teachers and a large industrial
the dynamic community of learners
committed to growing rich safe and
enjoyable educational value by
technology focus now I want to come down
to hear the school environment now we
walk through this all the time and we
sit in all the time so you might not
have to vote all that much thought too
because just kind of a given but think
about this the buildings are new light
filled spacious and carpeted don't
forget this is a relatively new school
their own scores and mcstay twitch are
decades old up the now squeak so it's a
very modern facility a huge FPC with a
full-size international basketball court
technology advanced environment without
entire school wires in there working for
14 computer labs student use an
agricultural some of the smaller an
agriculture area with a wide variety of
animals and plants easy access for
students with physical disabilities
which is a major fact that we need to
consider when you think about the space
that we're going to be designing
redesigning and what features it needs
to retain a large oval our door creaking
volleyball basketball and netball
facilities are covered outdoor learning
area a cork and multipurpose courtesan
you've seen all these spaces these are
photos that were taken at a time where
you can see that it does have the
capacity to be green and alive it's the
name and reflecting on those photographs
I took those
that we were down and how to look at the
top playground
everyone's seen it
because we I took them when I was with
you
we also know that it's probably not
going to be like that lady in detention
no no it's quite mine so what kinds of
designs would you implement that would
say how can we retain and encourage this
kind of flaw confirm okay miss with your
diamond right me through okay now in the
groups that we're going to establish
some of us already work together soon
sort of investigate the effect of
overpopulation within the sea THS
environment and make no mistake it is
overpopulation there is no school even
within the vicinity of 40 d mountable
classrooms de manuel classrooms are
intended to be a stopgap measure your
school is currently not big enough make
it a little bit bigger so that we can
have bring in a more permanent fixture
first amount hasn't been there a very
long time Oh population particularly
addressing the area this will refer to
the top level is your certificate
mathematical tools really devise a
potential solution to ameliorate that's
preventing French word needs make it
better ameliorate the tiger aspect of
the school environment the solution is
to be presented in groups of two to
three in a virtual model and some
aspects physical model by the way this
modeling process is so crucial for
understanding and communicating a
possible solution this is what we were
used to see when did this happen think
about it I don't mean a date move what
happened before this it range and that
that disaster pours down an i arrived
and scream very very early those days
and so I comment I see the cleaners in
the dark once it's dried scooping up
this soil manua there's no other way to
do it can you imagine what that's doing
to me to the top playground that all of
its nutrients are going literally down
the drain
our project increases addresses the
increasing urbanization of our local
community urbanization we live in a
recent thing of a sub urban environment
some suburbs but increasingly we are
becoming an urban environment townhouses
high density living and that's why there
is it's going to becoming even more
where the train station arrives the
population of this area of this scope as
visual within our school grounds through
the degradation of our common spaces of
top soil erosion there are the
significant effects that are not as
tangible essentials congestion in the
school between lessons as students move
from one device to another as well as
children not being able to remain
physically active due to the lack of
available space during recess and lunch
now just quick show of hands how many of
you have been in this course in c7 push
our hands ok thank you hands down the
vast majority of you as a result some of
you might not realize that a normal high
school doesn't look like our school at
recess and lunch there are hundreds
thousands of students sitting at benches
there on the oval they're running around
which you can't do because there's no
space to do it you might run into a man
they actually do exerciser this is a
real impact on our community you can see
how multifaceted multi-blade this issue
is and therefore how much your design
solution will also have to be to
encounter this problem excellent so the
other day we started discussing what
sort of things would constrain our
design
solution ie the limitations of the
design answer so I don't really want to
harp on this too much today because I
can go through it with you at another
time but what we did want to do today as
a group is we wanted to start to
identify things that you feel is
important to research now the other day
when I gave you the cherry brook train
station or the castle will train station
brief I said to you now you've assumed
the role of the engineer or the
scientist of the mathematician and I
want you to build it tomorrow I want you
to build this mega tomorrow what do you
need to know in order to make that
happen so we're going to open the floor
for about 10 minutes now 15 minutes
we're going to discuss this with you and
then we're going to extrapolate where
science comes into it where maps comes
into and where technology comes into it
and where engineering comes into it now
I wanted you to individually make a boob
let's nap because we're running short on
time we're going to do it all together
Matthew's favorably um we're going to do
it all together and then I'll put it up
on the Edmodo as a starting point for
you to develop your own research in your
groups so who wants to start ball
rolling tell us our research parks parks
so are you talking about fire
solution Oxford it's just like
playgrounds ervil's everything that the
council was to keep our parks still make
people run all over the variable don't
agree okay so what we would like to see
that is we would like to see design
solutions that are already operating is
that what you mean by that is ok society
probably switch to be compared photo
story of our stores photos of saber I
feel like because they have really
massive ovals and kids running around
either precursor to post here I'm so
glad one of the initial placement elixir
is existing solutions what are some
limitations of looking existing
solutions and their relevance to us
because we can't simply copy and paste
got a lot of three here so so there are
financial aspects yeah physical aspects
there are going to be parts of these
designs and hopefully we can borrow but
there are parts of these that are not
gonna play us at all so we have to be
dessert what other kinds of things do we
want to know we can I can hear a bit of
chat then same guys because what is but
about the cost of doing what the park
encountered eyes okay so you were
talking about
maintenance are you talking about the
cost of starting with a project from
scratch like we're defining the proofing
okay yeah and maintenance if you think
about it in the long term okay so mean
to be a las dos project and then what
we'll do is we'll put another little
toggle here that's maintenance and
construction
Oh
oh yeah
shoes
thank you just over a thousand well what
else do we need well what else do we
remain moms you have assumed the
position of the person working on this
there's a blood of independent a go
around so contribute it back to the
group you guys we're all using research
material students having two thousand
kids boys there every day is it a
durable thank you like if you consider
amazing i go by a colleague at the right
mental dead so if they consider that the
pathway in my core off and soon so
material yeah good posture the materials
I believe they taken today my poster
life the work is how many you can't just
five stuff it needs to be yeah oh yeah
so the all the trees and the barking
need to figure out how we can move like
balls and requirements is not for going
around those trees and four-way quick
look upon so talking about environmental
considerations yeah yeah those clothes
yeah you sound very good besides very
quietly written one day Lucas do you
have to make this tomorrow what would
you think so we need to look into what's
wrong with it now don't we yeah good so
what we're going to do as I might
actually put that under engineering I'm
going to put that into current issues
come on why do we need to fix this
tomorrow I'm invitation time good so we
need to value that in its time do we
have a time limitation that will yes we
do well not the not designing the
project but building it to have a
permanent case we have a time
limitations are planning the project and
then there's not necessarily a time
limit for construction because we don't
know how big or how small it will be and
there's a good chance we have to answer
some what of it so that's something that
we're going to consider once we've
finished the planning seating in like
the shelter arrangements ok so we're
sorry look at
no you're shopping for the late again
there is no cool person yeah I swear I
get wet in the rain that logic all right
and where we need to observe issues with
traffic flow because we discussed ensive
Lee the other day and cover shelter
shelter a lot about it right now it's
just been going and take off in this
side of the room anymore so yes
basically you know how we have one way
to go to cable maybe we should I will
will show you more long weeks
possibility of more what week like we
can have some sheltered so it's easier
to walk in the rain
I just talked about that under
engineering and I'm going to explain to
you why the other day the other day we
were discussing the role of civil
engineers and how they tend to be in
control or responsible for all of the
things in our environment that we take
for granted such as how does power flow
work on a grip how does waste get to the
waste disposal plant how do I get water
to my house now that is definitely a
civil engineering topic because that is
a problem now that we are drastically
overpopulated and I think that it's fair
to say that we are drastically
overpopulated there are not enough
bathrooms and nobody wife they've been
putting into malleable building so that
we can still teach you nobody sticks it
in the back of their own on top lockers
covers like a playground with Porter
loose I'm glad you mentioned Waterloo
even more glad that that inspires you
know score score for water from Wallace
because there's a real reason why
actually portals are kind of at the
moment I'm a parent situation they
probably the most practical because you
can't just put a toilet somewhere why
not what is it toilet meat in it mommy
needs loads of infrastructure I mean how
does he live in west coast here because
windows are too far away okay if you got
if you drive past western a neat recife
you might notice is that there are no
telegraph poles water telegraph board
and where is it pal go for it comes from
underground so clearly know some
infrastructure design McCracken there
right now infrastructure design and like
happened about three years ago the
deciding and planning would have been
prior to that but when I first started
working at cherrybrook I used to commute
from the Central Coast and on my way
down the hill they were constantly
digging up a different Road with the
power cables underground so that's only
a very recent development to keep Bob of
charity broken okay yeah yeah now it
does a lot on haircut they're open
purchase that's rather be right now well
more yeah like a good idea to start like
now i can bug crawling down onto the
court yes like so we need to have a look
at that in bed reading something you get
to me maybe i can all sort of stick
about the steps of this silly bug comes
and gets walked by that one step so
you're a bunch of trying and you're
providing me with a solution or like
your solution what would be the problems
what is that relate to put your life
yeah definitely but it also relates to
the ecosystem up there isn't it and we
started speaking about this the other
day and it's something that is the topic
of our of our project is the ecosystem
how does that work in relation to all of
the humans that are using it and how
does it react or what how does the
environment influence the design now
this could go on for hours and hours and
hours and hours and it probably work
we're probably going to dedicate another
lessons but what I want to do in the
last five minutes is mrs. yang has
something she wants you to start on
immediately and then she's hopefully
going to come back and visit you in the
last period this week and reflect on
that we do so i'm going to hand the
floor to house much
yes i have another point yep um you know
how are people like disabled people
example at the top playground there's
just stairs to go up there maybe we
should have a rant because I have
friends who have crutches like at least
you want to go just coming out the other
day somebody else yeah the way that
having a walkway that goes up past k 1
yeah it's completely inadequate that but
yeah or you go all the way past unless
we fukin yeah and you know what I worry
about these classes that you're already
so passionate about it I've been trying
to tell them that you look very
passionate about it so we can talk about
this for the next lesson we have to get
it right yeah that's a great to get your
days quickly so that were you need to do
what this concern with a science
discipline and looking at scientifically
the area around cherry in a round
cherrybrook the playground area and
we're looking at it you've been doing
presently aren't you doing our subjects
about a palm tree and then you became
ever taken a proponent and you be
looking at all the diffracting have done
the practicum or doing going to do a
preg most of you become like eh a little
bit of soil temperature not ever looking
at the soy whether there's any
degradation and I think we couldn't have
missed we could have a sawing meant to
come in fully yes to do a goose chase
for you Mike Haley hahaha conductions
connections the equipment that we have a
spore properties you know not as good as
what they have so we're trying to get
somebody to come and do the soy test so
that you can get more information
that one on the soil degradation and so
on now your main purpose would be for
next week or the next few lessons and
recess and lunch you'll be wandering
around the playground area looking at
how the traffic flow how people move and
is there a particular reason why they're
going that way and we're concentrating
so you be figuring out where your friend
what's the best way to to look at it
it's just the starting point we will
preliminary study just care research and
possibility or how you're gonna collect
the data and then after you come back in
groups and you're going to talk about
your discussion and then we are going
into the rail designing your
investigation okay so the first new
lesson of this week maybe one or two
lesson of this week you'll be going
around with your friends in your groups
and you'll be watching the click on
looking at how traffic flow what other
things you need so you might need to
brainstorm some ideas and how to collect
the data yeah is there any PC sound like
the investigation three times so either
recess there'll be populations of people
in various locations yeah and during
period so during period 12 period too
you'll have traffic loading all above on
the top layer somehow you'll have to see
how these traffic works obviously plant
or drink class time considering class
time everyone will be in class so in
your own time throughout this week I
would like you to have this in your mind
so that you can try and observe remember
the first thing we need to do is make
observations about how traffic is
flowing and see if we can just break
down key areas of the top playground so
that we can have a proper hypothesis
established now in order to collect that
day to day because we are asking you to
do this in your own time so you're going
to need to find a buddy that you can
work with or identify the group that you
want to work with but how can we capture
that data
photos good what else videos videos good
what else showing two things happen in
the playroom we have love song
dedications out there in college so what
you need to do is you need to work in
your group identify a recess or lunch
time and you need to make observation
does anyone have any questions about the
activity because we are expecting me to
do this in your own time groups all two
to three any more questions good all
right let's go period six great to see
you want